We had a bunch of interesting elections yesterday,
a very important reminder, a useful reminder
that we don't just have a presidential race
going on right now.
We have 435 House seat elections coming up
in November.
Many primaries for those happening in the
months leading up.
We have 35 Senate elections and the possibility
that Democrats would be able to take over
the Senate.
We've looked at that.
And yesterday there were a bunch of interesting
primaries that I want to talk about today.
Not at all.
Surprisingly, Congresswoman Alexandria Cosio
Cortez had a primary challenger who she easily
defeated.
The challenger was Michelle Caruso-Cabrera,
a CNBC host, former Republican, running now
as a Democrat, and AOC easily won.
As of right now, looks like AOC had about
73 percent of the vote in that race because
that's such a blue district.
The primary is essentially the general election,
like there will be a Republican on the ballot
against AOC in November.
But the fact that she won the primary all
but guarantees that AOC will get a second
term in the House of Representatives.
Another race that we were watching very closely
and we'll continue to watch closely now that
we have a primary winner is the Democratic
challenger against Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell for his Kentucky Senate seat.
Mitch McConnell has been one of the most successful
Republicans from the measurement, from the
standpoint of what he's been able to achieve,
as many of you know, an excellent and effective
tool for the right in getting a bunch of judges
confirmed, holding off, holding open a seat
on the Supreme Court that should have been
Barack Obama's to replace with Merrick Garland,
of obstructing Mitch McConnell that seat for
long enough that Donald Trump ended up getting
to choose.
Neil Gorsuch, an incredible coup victory for
Republicans, horrible for the world, horrible
for the country.
Never should have been allowed to happen.
But if you're a Republican, certainly Mitch
McConnell has been effective.
He has a serious primary challenge.
And Amy McGraths seemed to be the leader going
into the primary over the last couple of weeks.
There was some energy around Charles Booker,
a more progressive alternative in the Democratic
primary.
But indeed, Amy McGrath has won there with
about 45 percent of the vote.
That's a plurality.
Charles Booker only with about 36 percent
of the vote.
So we will see.
Amy, Magrath challenge.
Mitch McConnell, we've said before it's a
very uphill battle.
But even getting Mitch McConnell to have a
fight, even forcing Republicans nationally
to have to spend money to defend Mitch McConnell's
seat is great.
And she could actually win.
Amy McGrath was up by one point, a tie within
the margin of error, statistically speaking,
a couple of weeks ago.
That's going to be a great one to watch.
Interesting Republican primary in North Carolina
to mention where a 24 year old guy defeated
the Trump endorsed candidate in the Republican
primary for a House seat.
His name is Madison Cawthorn.
Trump endorsed his opponent, Linda Bennett.
This is the 11th Congressional District in
North Carolina.
That's the seat that was formerly held by
Trump's now latest chief of staff.
Mark Meadows, who's a horrible, horrible guy.
Unofficially, Cawthorn won very easily by
about seventy five to 25 margin.
This is a notable defeat for the Trump endorsed
candidate.
But it's important to remember that the guy
that won Cawthorn, he also loves Trump.
Trump endorsed his opponent.
But this is not like an anti Trump Republican.
That one.
Katherine loves Trump.
It's just that Trump picked somebody else.
So either way, if he wins in November, it's
still horrible.
Interestingly, he's not even old enough to
serve as of right now, but because he will
be 25 by the time he would be inaugurated,
he's allowed to be on the ballot.
He will go on to face the Democratic candidate,
Mo Davis, and that's a Republican leaning
district.
So that is sort of background level at a base
level that that is one that favors Republicans.
There are four congressional candidates who
support Medicare for all who won primaries
yesterday, Richie Torez, Jamal Bowman, Monder
Jones and Dana Baltar's.
So that's interesting and important.
And we'll see what happens with their races
in November.
And then a really interesting story out of
Virginia.
Dr Cameron Webb, I call him Webb, M.D.
That's how I refer to him.
But officially, Dr Cameron Webb, he won the
Democratic primary in Virginia's 5th District
and he will probably face off against Republican
Bob.
Good.
In November.
That would be a really great seat to turn
from red to blue.
Webb ran hugely on affordable health care.
He's a physician.
He was leading with 68 percent of the vote.
Last I checked.
So that's a big win for him.
That actually is a traditionally Republican
district, which is flippable.
And Virginia has been a what I call it.
Virginia has been a realistic focus of going
blue.
We've seen many elements of Virginia go blue
over the last eight, 10 years.
And officially, that race leans Republican,
but it is a winnable seat.
And we'll just have to see how the campaign
shakes out.
It's a wild district.
In that last election cycle, Republican Denver
Riggleman won the seat by about six points
and then was removed by the local Republican
convention because he officiated a gay wedding
for two of his old friends and campaign staffers.
Which is it?
It Virginia's been getting pulled blue.
It is still Virginia and this stuff still
exists there.
So a number of interesting races.
This ties into how will we vote in November?
The discussions of absentee ballots and vote
by mail.
We'll be talking about that later today.
The desire for scientists and educators and
doctors, at least on the Democratic side,
seems partially to be related to what we've
been seeing with Corona virus and the failed
federal response in the United States.
And that's exactly where I want to go next